حتى الثواني الاخيره من المباراه كان
الجمهور العماني متفاعلا مع مجريات مباراه
المنتخب السعودي امام بولندا ورغم الهزيمه
الا ان الجمهور العماني متفائل بيتاهل
المنتخب السعودي امام المكسيك في مباراته
المقبله
[تصفيق]
كانت قويه بس ان شاء الله الكاس السعوديه
ان شاء الله
الاخضر
فرحان شويه زعلان على النتيجه بس فرحان ما
شاء الله السعودي الاخضر السعودي قدم همم
محمد كرويه بس همم الحظ همم هذه المباراه
وان شاء الله مع المكسيك انا باذن الله
عندي تفائل كثير
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله همم الدور الثاني ان شاء الله
المنتخب السعودي قد ايه ووفاء ما شاء الله
وبيض يعني كل همم الخليج والامه العربيه
الاسلاميه اه اتوقع انه يقدر يرجعوا في
همم مباراه المكسيك ان شاء الله همم اليوم
للاسف في الحظ ما حاله في المنتخب السعودي
همم والفرصه فرصه
البرينتي اللي ضاعت حتى اثبت شويه معنويه
على
اللاعبين بس لكن يعني بشكل عام يعني هم
لعبوه ووفوا ما شاء الله